والمشاهد التي ترد من تلك المنطقه ان حجم
الاضرار كبير هناك اضرار في احد المباني
في تلك المنطقه هناك عدد من الطوابق التي
نصفت على ما يبدو بالل في هذا المبن
الموجود في منطقه الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت
وتحديدا منطقه المشرفيه ومعروف ان منطقه
المشرفيه هي منطقه مقتضى سكانيا وفيها
الكثير من المباني السكنيه المتلاصقه
والتوقيت الذي وقع فيه هذا الانفجار عند
الخامسه والنصف مساء بتوقيت بيروت تقريبا
يعني انها ساعه الذروه في تلك المنطقه وفي
عموم المناطق في العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت
ايضا هناك اضرار في السيارات الموجوده في
تلك المنطقه و طبعا كل فرق الاسعاف والفرق
المعنيه بعمليات الاخماد وعمليات الاسعاف
هرعت الى المكان بانتظار المعلومات التي
يمكن ان ترد في المرحله المقبله بشان هذا
الموضوع طبعا هذا الانفجار في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه لبيروت التي تعتبر معقلا اساسيا
لحزب الله ياتي هذا الانفجار في وقت حساس
ووقت دقيق وهو طبعا في مرحله ينخرط فيها
حزب الله عند جبهه جنوب لبنان في مواجهه
يمكن القول مفتوحه مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
ربطا بمعركه التي تحصل في قطاع غزه حزب
الله منذ اليوم الاول لعمليه طوفان الاقصى
كان يقول ان جبهه جنوب لبنان هي جبهه
مسانده جبهه دعم لقطاع غزه يوميا نطلق حزب
الله مجموع من الصواريخ المضاده للدروع من
القذائف تستهدف المستوطنات تستهدف
التجمعات تجمعات الجنود الاسرائيليين في
قباله الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان تستهدف
المراكز العسكريه الاسرائيليه ويرد الجانب
الاسرائيلي في مناطق جنوب لبنان من خلال
غارات مكثفه من خلال القصف على نقاط يقول
انها تابعه لحزب الله وبالتالي وقوع
الانفجار اليوم في هذه المرحله الحساسه في
خدام معركه طوفان الاقصى داخل الضح حيه
الجنوبيه لبيروت له ابعاد كثيره وله معان
كثيره بغض النظر عن اسباب هذا الانفجار هل
هو ناجم عن عمل امني ما هل هو عمليه
اغتيال على سبيل المثال هل هو متعلق بحدث
وقع في تلك المنطقه بغض النظر عن كل
السيناريوهات المطروحه في هذه اللحظه
التوقيت ومكان حصول هذا الانفجار يحمل
دلاله كبيره ودلاله من شانها ان تغير
المشهد الامني في لبنان ومشهد المواجهات
في جنوب لبن وكيفيه تعامل حزب الله مع
المساله في المرحله المقبله